if you're a car we're headed for a cliff
first thing is take your foot off the
accelerator I'm Bill Nye the Science Guy
everybody the science of climate change
is settled the science is real we have a
small cadre of climate change deniers
and they have been very good at their
jobs introducing the idea that
scientific uncertainty something like
plus or minus 2% is the same as plus or
minus 100 percent about doubt about the
whole thing the climate is changing
whether you are progressive or
conservative this is not red or blue
this is happening to everybody so what
you want to do about climate change I
understand it's very reasonable you
could run in a circle school but
generally it's not especially effective
there is so much extra carbon dioxide
put in the air so quickly there's a
certain amount of climate change is
baked in pun intended
however the sooner we get to work on
addressing these issues the better
life's going to be for everybody we got
to work the problem from both ends we
have to do more with less be less
inefficient and we have to produce
electricity renewably there is enough
wind energy and solar energy falling in
North America on North America that you
could power the whole place renewably
right now if you just decided to do it
if you just decided to revolutionize the
infrastructure the way we distribute
electricity what we want to do by the
way is Electrify all ground
transportation we want all buses trucks
trains and cars to be electric can I
just talk briefly then yes about
regulation regulation if we had a tax on
carbon and this would enable the free
market to address climate change if you
make extra carbon you pay more fee if
you reduce your carbon you pay less fee
so here's what I say to those of you who
think it just can't possibly be done oh
we just can't solve this global problem
oh I've done things the old way for two
and a half centuries and I just can't
bring myself okay here's what I say
individuals can do a lot
the big thing you can do as an
individual is vote you have to vote with
the environment in mind this is not like
oh I don't know we can do this people
we have historic precedent you can't
leave the earth I know there's some
romantic notion that you're go live on
Mars no no you can't go live on Mars
this is it this is where we're gonna
live here on the earth we're all in this
together so let's go people we can do
this MA